hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play linger now if
this looks different to you that's
because I am currently in what's going
to be my new office and it is completely
empty except for the floor which is a
giant train wreck of the computer parts
that I have been building now I ran out
of videos that were pre-recorded but I
decided that I needed to record
something in the meantime so I managed
to set up my oculus rift with this
camcorder that I got either way this
should be fun and or bad but either way
should be interesting so linkers game
where you going through a haunted house
and try to cleanse it if the evil that
resides within that's basically all
there is and I am a lady as you can see
this is still disorienting I don't even
need the mouse for this one and oh my
god excuse me and I didn't quite hear
that all I hear is this clock so effed
it oh my
okay so f to interact oh god is that
staring at new hi how's it Gabe Newell I
love it okay is that also Gabe Newell
that is definitely not Gabe Newell okay
so I don't have my Xbox controller with
me so I can't control where I go I
basically have to back and forward as
I'm looking in the direction oh it's a
haunted toilet why is there a haunted
toilet in here is this one of the toilet
from the prop hunt video that we did oh
I gotta cleanse it I gotta cleanse it
with my holy water no one look tada
okay what well I guess that's it then
what's interesting about this place is I
can actually turn around because I'm
standing up right now so I gotta wait oh
god am I gonna do this I guess do this
why is there dark energy over there wait
a minute no excuse me pardon me this is
very disorienting just please bide with
me I also have a mouse here so I'm gonna
try to use that to my advantage that's
probably just gonna make things hi
someone in there someone want to say hi
to me okay no one or also I got a quite
a bit of an echo in here because I don't
have it exactly sound
proved yet it's just a room and my voice
projects quite a bit anybody up there
anybody want to say hi to me loose
suck my water down evil spirits begone
from this place ok ok I'll bite go then
I wonder what horrors await me up here
ok I see some dark spirit oh god what's
it I thought that was a teddy bear at
first hello you're terrifying like whoa
what did i do what did i do why you okay
you're disturbing I'm gonna go away now
alright let's just go find the dark
energy and see what happens afterwards I
cleanse the sploosh da da
well those my party trick anything in
here Hoopa I know it's bright for the
camcorder mm-hmm okay you gotta do
something this time aren't you little
doll girl okay who's that wasn't weird
at all okay
need I remind okay this is also
disturbing for me because I'm in a new
place and I don't know if there's like
someone standing right behind me or
something no idea okay oh okay
anymore it's not gonna be it okie dokie
hi how are you doing today you're doing
good it good to hear all the family oh
good a mirror oh I thought I had no
reflection damn I'm gorgeous
look at me I'm also jacket was it oh
hello baby
I mean me I mean here right
that okay I don't see anything else what
else is going on here I heard that you
want to tell me I didn't hear that
I also haven't soundproof this room so I
might be disturbing my neighbors very
much if that is a new sound that's not
coming from that room remember don't
agree oh okay here we go
Gabe Newell please save me
splooge why is it still do that why is
it still Oh more ah what is this gonna
add to Gabe Newell okay I don't like
this loose okay what does that mean
okay okay you're still doing the flicker
dance I don't want to give too loud Oh
in the entryway why here what places you
know I don't think this holy water is
doing much I think they might just be
laughing at me douche okay I'm actually
curious it
okay you're hmm yeah okay I heard that
and you need to shut up okay
Erin that sounds good I can run I'm so
used to not running all right uh-huh
quit up lip Oh play your game oh god
that was creepy
okay whew Junie
why why would you just move I don't know
what's going on ride best of that door
stays cool I knew something was wrong
with my reflection in there another one
spruce no come on
sploosh okay oh hey look a game play
that one so so far you've just been
slamming doors in my face not
particularly scary here's another one
hello Zeus all right okay
who's knocking look at me no you're
looking at me is there gonna meet you
little girl
stop looking at me
okay all right okay moving over here in
this room
okay this toilet isn't very haunted okay
come on here oh it was a double needed
extra juice let that lock on me hmm how
about you don't how much you don't I bet
you don't sit yeah but you don't say you
did I don't know if you guys are getting
this dynamic that I've got in this room
why are you swinging why what I don't
like is movement
oh you digging with me you're all
digging with me no stinky toilet in here
any ghost poop happening I want to know
I want to know right now
my neighbors have no idea what's
happening in here I love you Pookie
Tokyo but you dude
let's get over you're in this model okay
watch it don't work there would you stop
throwing stuff at me you dick oh you
died that's so sad except it's not
I curse you is everlasting death okay
this is good okay god thing quick just
balls an ass open up glue splashing uh
splishy okay things are starting to get
a bit more paranormal in here okay yeah
you can knock I've seen most of your
tricks what I've seen that trick before
what have you got that's new that's new
I don't think I want to come on alright
yeah okay tell you were you naked it
looks rather naked whatever you hmm
drop it stop it okay jappa there's
another glowy over there I'll get it in
a second
oh you closed the door on me huh who's
those hairy ah that TV I just bought
that and we actually did I just want to
be decent okay did I hear a sound from
in here no you're still dead oh okay
what ghosts keep hope you never mind of
those are hot tubs the lamp okay okay
I'm okay all right let's just get out
here it's dark in here
it's dark here huh it's light on my
webcam but it's okay maybe oh did I die
oh come on
maybe I should have gotten out of the
house I can't see anything is there
anything happening
aa-men thousand damn it
mmm oh I don't know if I lost there if I
wonder if that's the only it they have
either way oh man those weird weird
being in a new room a little paranoid
now but that was fun that was a lot of
fun seriously though there's a lot of
fun I hope my neighbors weren't you
angry because there's no acoustic foam
underneath these walls or anything like
that but either way um that was fun okay
so thank you all so much for watching
there's gonna be a vlog showing off my
new house and the things that I've done
to set it up and I'm gonna give a a demo
for the computer because I know that a
lot of guys have really wanted me to
show off my computer and I'm really
proud of this one it's probably the best
build I've ever done I always build my
own computers so that's why mine are
always Frankenstein monsters of
assembled parts but either way that was
really fun is that a ghost Eagle yeah
got that one okay so thank you everybody
so much for watching I designed I've
done and that's all Wednesday we'll see
you ah Jesus Jesus ah ha oh ha ha ha ha
okay bad bad in here holy balls sad
hearts holy balls balls
yeah Wow yeah
I'm so sorry